Superman was in a porno
and you guys thought the flash was the
fastest man alive so all the way back in
Action Comics number 592 the story
starts with big barda's purse being
snatched which contains a powerful
weapon called the mega rod
might be a little on the nose there guys
but the thief a character named sleaze
uses the mega Rod to force big varda to
perform on camera now Superman sensing
the immense power being used here
investigates and is knocked out along
with big Barta now under the control of
the mega Rod slice takes Superman and
Barta to a studio to uh make their film
debut in their efforts to make it in
Hollywood but back on apocalypse Mr
Miracle returns home to find Darkseid in
his living room now when dark side is
asked about barta's whereabouts Darkseid
plays the recording the sleeves made of
her of course outraged Mr Miracle sets
off to rescue his wife arriving just in
time to free both Superman and big Barda
from sleaze's control 80s were a weird
time man make sure you follow for more